talk about a little bit here let me i
have something i mean just being around
this
space what do you think goes on here
because i kind of talked to doug and
george well we should explain what the
place looks like to the audio
actually yeah jules could you describe
that yeah let's have jules
clap the boat this place
give me a spider
what it looks like it has a lot of
joshua tree
that's the first thing you notice with
that all that up right there literally
from where we're sitting there's not a
single joshua tree inside
oh yeah joe's like the one i've been
looking at the whole time there's one
the one there's so many josh one tree
there's a dirty couch okay
um a lot of trailers
can i tell you the first thing i noticed
what like the other day we were driving
we saw the sheep
what sheet sheep oh those are goats babe
whatever hey what's the difference
tomato tomato what's the difference
there's a big difference one's a gold
one's a sheep but they're white and
fluffy
no thank you which one do you think
brown coats
okay wait what do you think the
difference if you had to
figure it out what is the difference
between a sheep and a goat okay noise
wise what sound is oh go with me let's
start with noise
oh go goes right cool
energy goes like that are you just doing
vowels
i already know jules and i have the same
exact answer yeah wait what's the
american sound for
for goats no
wait what the hell the horse has a horse
yeah let me see okay let me let me do
some animal sounds i really
i will try my best to do it yeah i mean
and see what you you think it is all
right
good wow yeah um let's just do obvious
ones first
is that obvious chicken
no i i know this is because
oh i have dog yeah it's not babe
you do ow it's rough
a little more exotic exotic dog all
right so my bad okay so let's go
chinese crested
how about this one this one because i've
been trying to i try to do a
bit about this and so i went online i
went to youtube to see what these
animals sound like
and i could never get it down but this
is
[Music]
one more time please
koala no oh close
no kangaroo um no well it's gotta be
some
australian one now is he throwing this
off by saying it's close to koala
no i'm not cool well i mean koala's a
similar sound
uh wall has a similar sound d okay let
me
narrow it down all right they they
definitely you can find them on islands
uh-huh
right and probably generally papua new
guinea
it's the um it's the bird of paradise no
tortoise oh sloth sloth makes that sound
they do sound like they do yeah okay
what are their animal sounds i wanna
just go back to animal sounds i wanna
know what you think a goat sounds like
again
um not that far
actually that but that's more like a
sheep let's hear your goat
goats okay i don't know what these sound
like but i'm gonna just see if i can see
come on let me try to do with my all
right
rhino yes yeah cause your hand not the
sound
[Laughter]
i wanted to help out the sound okay so
but i think that with my hand because i
don't know what they sound like
so i'm just
if they're just walking chilling without
making big specifically to me that's
more like a kawaii chicken the brown
ones
that's what i'm familiar with they're
just chilling right yeah i was doing
kawaii if they're trying to like if it's
a rooster it's definitely
oh
[Music]
did that i was expecting the same amount
of syllables
all right how about okay how about and
let's i'll do an animal
i don't even know if they make sounds
we'll just save what you know i mean so
what would a turtle sound like
that's mine don't turtles make that like
when they're having sex they go
i've never seen turtles having sex
skills not my face yeah that's not
me that i look up to me either yeah yeah
god wait wait let me ask you something
what
let me ask you a question claudio
claudia claudio
that you know they know why they have
sex is they do this with their
flippers they face each other yes and
they do this well when it's so hot they
wave their hands
you explain to him what like how they
position and it's a screech
i i've never you know you might be right
guilt there might be a screech but i
just know that they they do this
okay what am i doing right now
okay well i was i got one right let's
see i think we should have tiger belly
animal sounds coffee book
please um what does a bunny rabbit sound
like
i don't know i've never heard of bunny
that's all folks that's
about it that's the only bunny that's a
guy yeah what's up doc
oh oh oh what's up duck is more famous
what's the other one yeah is that the
pig
yeah that's how i did porky pig i did
porky pig sorry yeah
i was watching an antique road show
yesterday and i got painted from what oh
that's right yeah yeah
so he so he was um in the viet
he was stationed in thailand during the
vietnam war
and he goes you know what i want to get
a rolex
and they were at the time it was 475
and he you know they don't get paid that
much so he saved up all his money
he got it and he said he spent so much
money on it
that he just put it in a [ __ ] safe